hello everyone
and welcome to today's live broadcast
cell sorting for multiple applications
how to optimize your sort setup i am jen
woods of lab roots and i'll be your
moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by lab roots and
sponsored by sony biotechnology
for more information about our sponsor
please visit their site
at sony sonybiotechnology.com
now let's get started i would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and
click on the send button if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
i'd like to now introduce our presenters
dr
dina sony global marketing manager sony
biotechnology
and dr miro coolness senior application
scientist
sony biotechnology for a complete
biography on our speakers please visit
the biography tab at the top of your
screen
before we begin the presentation we have
a quick poll for you
which professional position best applies
to you
dr sony you may now begin your
presentation
thank you for the introduction and
welcome to today's webinar on
optimizing sort setup for multiple
application
my name is dina sony and in today's
presentation i will be discussing
key considerations for sorting looking
at the influence of sample preparation
on a successful
sort outcome we will review how
a user can set up a sales order using a
streamlined approach
and what are the sort parameters that
should be chosen during sort setup
in the second half of this webinar my
colleague
miro coolness will do a deep dive on
setting up
multiple applications using diverse
samples
sharing with us how these can be set up
seamlessly on the same
instrument in a multi-user lab
let's get started
optimal sample prep is critical to
successful cell sorting
as the cellular sample becomes more
complex either in terms of
its heterogeneity or geometry and size
sorting them easily becomes challenging
a good sample prep can be obtained by
keeping three things in mind one
the cells should be maintained as a
single cell suspension
two the sample concentration should be
kept at recommended levels and three
at all times the single cells should be
maintained
in a suspension by agitation and cooling
so here's here are some of the
recommended approaches to generating
a single cell suspension number one
harvest the cells using trypsin
acutase or other enzymatic methods
inactivate these enzymes using
therm-free media
such as edta buffer and then wash the
cells
in calcium and magnesium free buffer to
reduce clumping
finally add dnas to remove any free
floating dna
and keep the final sample prep on ice
prior to sorting
once a single cell suspension is
obtained the cell concentration should
be adjusted depending on the type of
cells that are used
at the table listed below different
types of cells and their recommended
concentrations are shown
typically regardless of the cell size if
the sample is sticky
either due to the presence of debris or
dna
or simply because of the nature of the
source from which it was derived
then such a sample should be run more
dilute
in the last step in optimizing the
sample prep
keeping the cells in a single cell
suspension is important
this is done by filtering them and
keeping them
keeping them cold both before the sort
and then throughout the sorting process
now let's look at the steps of setting
up a cell sorter
the first step of sorter setup is of
course selecting the correct nozzle
for using the correct nozzle for sorting
your cells
choose an orifice that is at least five
times the size of your cell
smaller nozzles generate more droplets
and are ideal for fast
sorting of common cell types like yeast
lymphocytes and splenocytes as the
nozzle size
increases it produces lesser number of
droplets per second
but on the other hand it provides a
larger drop volume
this in turn could improve sorting of
cells that are not only
large like the chose cells but also
cells that have
irregular geometry like the neurons
once you have selected the nozzle the
instrument must be calibrated for
detecting and sorting cells
in case of the sony sorters it is a
completely automated process
where the flow cell or the chip is
aligned to the lasers
to ensure optimal signal on a daily
basis
next the laser delay is determined
followed by which
droplet calibration is done to determine
the breakoff point
in the last steps the deflection of the
site stream is optimized
for two and four-way sorting and lastly
the sword delay is calculated
so let's review all the steps of setting
up a system for sorting
a systematic and streamlined approach to
sort
setup is possible when using an
automated
cell sorter like the sony ma900
on this system the microfluidics chip
represents
both the flow cell and the nozzle and is
available in different sizes
to support sorting of different cell
types
the sorting chip is a user exchangeable
consumable
and includes distinct ports
through which sheath and sample are
injected for
the cell sorting process also vacuum can
be drawn
on the chip to eliminate any trapped air
that may occur
during the sorter operation and lastly
at the bottom of the chip there is an
integrated nozzle
of a defined orifice size of 1700
or 130 micron diameter
setting up the ma900 can be done in two
basic steps
in step one the user scans the qr code
on the microfluidics chip
and loads it on the system this qr code
automatically inputs baseline settings
required for that chip
size once the chip is loaded in the
system
the user can then perform step two
which is auto calibration
in this step the user loads auto setup
beats
and then the system takes over and all
the steps of system
setup that we discussed before which
include chip alignment laser delay
break off optimization side stream
adjustment and drop delay
are all executed automatically
and the system is ready for setup in
less than 30 minutes
in the next steps the different
parameters required to set up a sorting
experiment
are selected as shown in this image
sort setup begins with creating an
experiment from
a blank template or by using an existing
template
a template brings in different
measurement settings
including a choice of lasers and
fluorescence and scatter parameters
that are required for your experiment
based on your application the required
measurement settings
must be selected in step two for example
in the me 900 cells order the user has a
choice of four lasers
and 12 fluorescents and two scatter
parameters
for which area height and width
measurements
are available
once the measurement settings are
selected compensation tubes are
automatically created in the software
under the new experiment
single stain compensation controls can
be then
run to create a compensation matrix a
multi-color sample
which will be sorted is next run
and analyze to create a great gating
hierarchy
and define the populations that will be
sorted
lastly the collection devices are set up
and sorting is initiated
on the m8900 cell sorter the user has a
choice
of sorting into two and four-way tubes
using peltier-coupled tube holders
that keep the sample cold at all times
alternatively
single cell sorting into plates can also
be performed
again using special holders that provide
a precise fit for different types of
plates
so this was a complete overview of how
to set up for sorting
we will next look into how to optimize
sorting
for different applications on the same
instrument
hi everyone thanks for being with us on
this webinar and thank you dina for
introducing the sorting workflow
my name is mirakulnus and i'm a senior
field application specialist with sony
biotechnology
i will continue by looking in more
detail at a few different applications
user might encounter all in the same day
of sorting on an instrument
we'll cover yeast sorting and cleaning
followed by some high parameter panel
data
and finish up by looking at plate
sorting of large cells
let's start with yeast sorting an
example of this application might be
working with these surface displays
human antibody libraries
for the nova discovery of therapeutic
antibodies especially for a non-expert
the challenge is often to correctly
identify targets using software tools
to maximize target yield resolve clogs
and to leave the instrument clean for
the users who run mammalian sales next
very often new users have a hard time
identifying
where the cell population is in this
category
this is because each instrument software
may look different and have different
threshold and scatter default settings
however with experience you realize that
in fact all flow cytometers detect cells
using the same principles
and should have the same three main
settings let's briefly go through them
first you want to adjust the forward and
side scatter voltages to place the yeast
population in view on the plot
you can also use either log or linear
scales to visualize your data
in addition i would make sure that the
threshold is not set too high
otherwise half of your population may be
ignored by the instrument
and if you're really not sure you may
run cell media alone to figure out where
the debris ends
and cell population would begin in your
plot
yeast cells typically have two
sub-populations the main population and
it's near to the upper right hand corner
which are most often aggregates because
yeasts are a monoculture
there are no particular rules other than
to gate on the majority of the
population away from debris or very
large and rare outliers
further on most users would like to
formally exclude doublets using voltage
pulse area versus false height
on the right the doublets are shown on
the second plot in the lower population
within the red gate
it is commonplace to exclude doublets to
achieve high purity
however if the yeast target is very rare
contains unusual morphology due to
budding
and requires enrichment sorting then
consider including those doublets
let's look at fluorescent detection
typical yeast applications do not
require a high parameter number
on a laser-separated system with 12
detectors it is easy to design a panel
that requires no compensation
also sony software contains a very
useful manual compensation tool
over on the compensation can be adjusted
manually by dragging the populations in
the plot
or you could follow the autocompensation
wizard as well
finally four-way sword capability allows
sorting multiple populations to identify
different binding affinity levels you
also want to take advantage of the
software tools to gate on your target
correctly
for example you can create plot overlays
of various control samples
with your actively sorted sample finally
it's a good idea to adjust the scaling
to see if any data are spread below zero
that way you're not missing a large
number of your targets in your gating
after gating on your target you've got
to set a sort mode
which will determine the levels of
purity and recovery
one type of mode popular in these
sorting is called an enrichment or yield
mode
this mode sorts target cells even if the
unwanted cells are present
and it can sort extra droplets to ensure
cell recovery
for yeast sorting this mode can help
enrich for your target by hundreds fold
another big advantage is that it can be
run extremely fast
close to your actual droplet rate and if
you have large sample volumes
70 micron nozzle is the fastest nozzle
to use
that way you can get to hundreds of
millions of cells quickly to enrich for
your target
another mode type is called purity
sorting in these mode types achieves a
very high purity at the expense of the
boarding targets
if a non-target is nearby as shown here
on the right
and for yeast sorting this mode may be
used after multiple rounds of enrichment
sorting to clean up any remaining
non-targets
here's a quick example with some numbers
on the left is an example of a purity
sort where cells were sorted slower
and you lost about 10 percent of your
targets to waste
however the purity was very good at 98
or 99
and on the right is an example of a
yield sort where the event rate was
three times higher
and took only 45 minutes the advantage
there was efficiency and speed
and you've recovered close to 100 of
your available targets
and even the purity in this case was not
too bad at 96 percent
what are the challenges of sorting yeast
well very high concentrations of these
cells are typically used for sorting
therefore sample line and nozzle
clogging is often observed with this
sample
here on the left you can see the event
rate changed to zero indicating a sample
path clog
while on the right the image shows that
the droplet generation is disrupted
because there is a clog in the nozzle so
it is especially important to watch out
for clogs
on the 70 micron nozzle which is the
narrowest of the three
sizes that we offer and therefore it is
the most troublesome
so i would recommend that you refilter
yourself throughout the sorting process
as often as every 20 minutes because the
onboard agitation may not prevent cell
aggregation especially if yeast are at a
high concentration
so many sorting chips are clog resistant
which is a huge benefit in yeast sorting
this is because the vast majority of the
time the clog occurs in the sample line
or the chip's sample input needle
critically
the droplet stream from the nozzle
remains undisrupted
and in calibration
on the sony system clogging can be
resolved by sample line backflash with a
click of a button
this process takes only one or two
minutes and can even be done remotely
you may also want to refilter the sample
before reloading it for
continuing the sort
once you've completed a yeast sort it is
time to clean the instrument
to prepare it for the next user if your
instrument is used only for yeast
a simple bleach and water should suffice
however in a multi-use scenario
it may help to completely isolate the
sample path between these two mammalian
samples
on sony ma-900 sales order for example
it takes only a few minutes
to switch from one sample line to
another to prevent any chance of
cross-contamination
for a very thorough cleaning of the
entire fluidic system
you may use 1 bleach or 70 ethanol to
maintain aseptic conditions
sonia may 900 sorters have automated
cleaning protocols with customizable
settings
and even the cleaning reminders so
together
all these features give you the benefit
of using the instrument
not only for yeast but for a variety of
other applications across different user
groups
now let's look at the kinds of topics
one encounters when sorting immune cells
with many subpopulations
peripheral blood mononuclear cells or
pbmcs
are the classical example of a
multicolored sample type
although these cells are easy to work
with small and generally are clog free
there's a wide variety of
sub-populations with drastically
different functions
therefore we typically identify the
target cells with a lot of different
markers for
chromes here you can see an example of a
12-color tbnk panel
on a three or four laser ma-900
instrument
perhaps the question users ask is how
many lasers
and detectors does an instrument have
and what is the optical layout of the
system
here are the fluorochrome choices for
ma900
this instrument has four lasers with 48
and 561 on the first beam spot
and the 405 and the 638 on the second
48 laser is also used to excite the
forward and the side scatter
as shown on the top there are five
detectors from the 4d8 561 laser line
with yellow green laser used to excite
fluorescent proteins
and on the bottom we have seven
detectors off of the 405 638 laser line
so to design your panel you would pick
one color from each column
if your samples do not express any
fluorescent proteins you do not
need to use the 561 laser because you
still get five detector channels
from the 48 laser line shown in this
slide is an example of the 12 color
panel using just three lasers
similarly a two laser system shown in
panel b on the right
still gives you a capability to run a 12
color panel
so overall ma900 optical design is
flexible
to support the transfer of 12 color
panels from other instruments
without changing optical configuration
once you have your samples ready it is
pretty straightforward to create an
experiment by selecting channels on the
lasers
as deena has described for you if
multiple fluorescent channels are
activated
the software prompts you to follow the
compensation wizard
so what are the best practices for
multi-color flow cytometry
for one you've got to have an unstained
control without the viability dye in it
single color controls can be prepared
using antibody capture beads
or with cells if your marker expression
is sufficiently high
and they should be at a similar or
higher brightness level to estimate the
spillover values correctly
once you have your controls the
compensation wizard will guide you
through recording them
one by one and calculating the
compensation matrix
shown here in the slide on the right
finally please remember that all
controls and samples
are run at the same pmt voltage after
calculating the compensation matrix
changing detector sensitivity on the fly
will invalidate that compensation
map and your gating will be affected
for those of you who might only be
learning about compensation
i would pose a question why does
compensation matter
here is an example of the data with no
compensation applied
here we can see the tell-tale signs of
multiple intermediate
and diagonal populations which
biologically should be single positive
this obviously is a result of
fluorochrome spilling into the adjacent
detectors
after running single color controls and
calculating the spillover correction
values we now observe only the true
biological pattern of marker expression
sorting the immune cells is fairly
straightforward once you've gated on
them
you would run a sword sample at
one-fifth the frequency of the nozzle
so for example on the 70-micron nozzle
you would run at 12
000 events per second then you would
probably sort four-way
into fax tubes with media where each
stream has been accurately targeted
you would also observe the event rate
and sword efficiency during sorting
and troubleshoot any encountered clogs
as i've discussed on previous slides
purity check sacrifices some sort itself
to give us the confidence
that the sort went well here are some of
the critical factors you should consider
you should be concerned about the
carryover in the sample line and i would
suggest running sample line rinse before
the purity checks
also be aware that cells may fall out of
the sword gate which results from the
dye washing off
photo bleaching or normal detective
variability
you may also want to look if scatter
shifts as an indication of viability
post sort
or restain cells with a viability die
overall i'd say that a purity of more
than 98
and efficiency of over 80 or 90
can be expected for experiments that are
set up using best practices
for my third topic i will discuss
sorting large cells into a plate
which is yet another application that
sony ma900
excels at
when we say large south we often mean
mammalian or even plant cells over 20
microns in diameter
such as cancer cell lines primary
fibroblasts stromal cells
cardiomyocytes epithelial cells and
neural cells
we also know that many users require
sorting these cells
into a plate for cell cloning or single
cell pcr applications
you might have guessed correctly that
sorting large cells is challenging due
to their size and sensitivity
to shear stress this is why sample
preparation
and nozzle choice sword settings and
plate hardware are also critical to this
process
for those of you who are interested to
learn a bit more about this application
i would suggest looking at my previous
webinar recorded in may of this year
today i will emphasize some of those
best practices as well as discuss
additional useful features you might
need for plating large cells
here is one good example which is u2 os
cell sorting with index function
this slide shows a typical gating scheme
starting from cells
most of which are viable followed by
singlet gating
and sorting for different levels of gfp
expression at one cell per well
the two plots on the right also show you
an index data analysis feature
you might ask what is index data index
data refers to each cell's fluorescence
and scattered data correlated with
plates well positioned
and it is most useful when doing single
cell deposition into multi-well plates
as you recall we started our sorting day
on sony ma900
for these cells and the 70 micron nozzle
followed by sample line exchange
and system-wide bleach cleaning and then
we sorted pbmcs into a tube
this slide here describes how one can
easily switch from tube sort to a plate
sort format
only in a couple of minutes
once the brake hardware is set it is
time to filter the cells
and then preview and gate on live cells
making sure that your forward and side
scatter detector voltages
are set low enough not to miss any cells
one tip i can give is to start with a
very low forward scatter setting
and incrementally increase it until you
see the main population outline
another tip is to do a quick sort of the
cell gate
onto a glass slide to make sure that the
cells are there instead of debris
finally for single cell cloning you must
take out doublet
now let's go over the instrument setup
from my webinar in may you might recall
that large fragile cells
should be sorted using 130 micron nozzle
this low pressure nozzle gives the best
cell viability
and the most precise droplet targeting
into a well
further you must use a single cell mode
to prevent two targets from getting
sorted
into one well it is critical to realize
that just because you've gated on
singlets
it does not mean that two singlets
cannot be in the same or adjacent
droplets
i would also suggest keeping samples
chilled and agitating
and run sticky cells more dilute at a
lower event rate
most often you only need 96 targets and
if they are above the one percent in
abundance
then you can run them at under 200
events per second
and your plate will be done in under a
few minutes
finally i suggest sorting cells into
warm condition media for best cell
survival
sony sorters provide users with a
variety of plate holders to fit almost
any plate type
critically to reduce a chance of
depositing a droplet on the sidewall of
a pcr well
or a 384 tissue culture well i would
suggest using an
angled plate holder as shown in the
middle of the slide
this angle of the plate holder helps the
dropper to reach the bottom of the well
where the lysis buffer is this is how we
can achieve a very high plate well
occupancy rate of about
95 percent to do so you must leave the
plate cover on
and then align the droplets to the
wealth center which we will look at next
sony sorters ought to calibrate stream
angles to hit the centers of fax
collection tubes
however as shown on the right additional
alignment tools are available
for fine-tuning the plate coordinates
importantly
you can perform a test sort onto a plate
cover using yourself in the droplets
and you can adjust each corner's
alignment independently of the other
corners
it takes only a couple of minutes to
follow the steps outlined here
and a lot of times 96 wall plates are
already close to perfect alignment
so if you're sorting large cells 130
micron nozzle will help to deliver them
to the centers of the wells at the top
of the slide here you can see a puddle
of 10 to 20 droplets
that land perfectly on the other hand
on the bottom is an example of using a
smaller diameter nozzle
which may not get your cells into the
well
sony software allows you to sort
different populations and different cell
numbers
in each well so after you've performed
plate alignment you would then create a
plate sort layout
for your targets and begin sorting
let's go back to the index sorting and
look at how does it work
if a cell satisfies a sorting criteria
the instrument will place the droplet
with that cell in it
into the well there is one cell
two cells three cells so on and so forth
as the previous slides showed the ma900
software records
indexed single cell data to correlate
fluorescence data with each
target's well position in this slide on
the right are a few examples of our data
analysis tools
one is called well select mode which
shows each selected well in the plots
another mode is gate select mode which
identifies
all wells with targets from a particular
gate
these software features allow us to
perform a metadata analysis
for downstream cloning and sequencing
experiments
here is an example of what you can do
with index data
because the data exportable as a csv
file you may correlate your gene
expression level
with the fluorescent marker expression
as shown here in the plot on the right
so in summary the main message of our
webinar is that there are many
challenging applications in self
switching
the learning curve can be steep and
there are a number of key sort
parameters for you to consider
finally it is fair to say that it is
hard to design a versatile
automated system with a variety of
features to cover all of the
applications
and we hope that after today you will
have a better idea on how sony ma900
streamlines and automates the sorting
workflow
thank you so much for your time and now
we can take any questions
thank you dr sony and dr coolness for
your informative presentation
we have two more questions for our
audience
if you could take a moment to look at
the questions and participate we greatly
appreciate it
thank you for your participation we will
now start the live
q a portion of the webinar if you have a
question you would like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen
and we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
our first question is
does the sony sorting chip get saturated
after running one experiment
what if i want to use the chip for the
entire day for sorting
i can take that question so the sony
sorting chip
can be scanned and used for the whole
day for
24 hours it does not get saturated
regardless of you know how many samples
you run
if there is any air or
cells that get trapped or clogged in the
chip
over the course of the day those can be
resolved simply by priming the chip
or doing a back flush as we showed in
our presentation
thank you dr sony the second question is
if yeast cells are subjected to
successive rounds of enrichment sorting
for faster throughput
what is the impact of this on their
viability
yeah i can take that so generally the
yeast
cells are very hardy and you can sort
and sort them at a high rate and and
their viability doesn't suffer i mean
i have customers who um sometimes
tell me that they sort these cells into
a dry tube because they
they survive so well so i would say that
the impact can be minimal especially if
you allow cells to recover
um after the first round of enrichment
sorting so if you grow them for a couple
of days
then you sort them again
so overall the impact on viability is
usually minimal
thank you dr coolness our next question
is there any advantage to using single
stained cells versus single stained
beads for compensation
um so i can also take that
so you can definitely use
either cells or beads for the
compensation
so the advantages of the um i will
answer it this way so the advantages of
using the compensation beads
is that if you don't have a good strong
cell
positive control the beat provides
a high level of fluorescence capture on
the beat surface to have a good positive
control
um however the advantage of using cells
is that uh you estimate the
autofluorescent background best
so a lot of it kind of does depend
on you know the setup of your experiment
too
which fluorochromes you're using but
generally i stick to either using all
beads or all cells and
i realize there's a lot more to that and
it does become kind of situation
dependent
but generally you can use either one as
long as your single positives are nice
and bright
okay thank you we have another question
i am using very large cells with
elliptical shape for sorting
any tips on how i can improve single
cell deposition on 96 well plates
yeah i can i can answer that as well um
so we've already covered a lot of those
aspects um
but i can kind of restate them again so
when you sort cells into a plate
um it's it's always good to use a 130
micron nozzle
especially if the cell is very large and
irregularly shaped
so certainly 130 nozzle helps as well as
using
three drop mode so there are uh sort
modes that
deviate um for each target cell either
one droplet so the cell is in that
droplet or you could also set up a
cell sorter to sort using a three drop
mode
and um depending on your uh on the
instrument you're using
um 130 micron nozzles for example
sometimes they can by default uh sort
three droplets at a time
uh so definitely uh use a three drop
mode
and make sure that you align the plate
really well
using cells when you're doing plate
alignment
uh when you're doing test sort onto a
plate cover
i would also say make sure that you use
enough buffer
in your wells so it's not you know
it has the largest surface area to to
basically capture that droplet
or the three droplets if you're using
last tip would be to perhaps not sort
uh too fast uh because the more targets
uh if you're doing multiple targets uh
per well the more targets you have
um you know the more fainting you will
experience and i guess
perhaps that that's a different uh part
to this question because we're talking
about single cell deposition
um but um in any case if you slow down
the
total rate that reduces the fanning
and improves the targeting into uh into
a well
thank you dr coolness we have another
audience question
what about index sorting software
yeah so um i've seen this question come
through
um i think we've covered pretty
extensively in the last
uh five slides of our webinar so i would
i i would just guide uh that
audience member back to those slides um
after this has been
made available for the you know post
recording view
okay great we have another question did
the sorting chips have a limited shelf
life and cannot
be used from scanned after a period of
time
yeah yeah i can take that question sorry
yeah
go ahead all right thank you so um
uh like we discussed before um once this
sorting chip has been scanned uh it has
a 24-hour
um you know lifetime for usage of course
if we talk about shelf
life per se which means you know just
storage um at the bench
there is no expiration date you purchase
the chip you can pretty much use it for
you know you can store it for years to
come
okay thank you um dr sony our next
question
how does the sony ma900 address
biosafety level
when sorting human cell or cell lines
would these cells be categorized as bsl2
or bsl2 plus
yeah i can take that one as well so uh
the sony ma900n all the other sony
solders as well
they have a provision where
they can either be installed inside a
biosafety cabinet which is a custom
product available from sony that enables
our customers to sort
and as well as bsl-3 type of
applications
we also have an ability to attach
the cell sorter to
an aerosol management system and then
depending on the kind of
cells you're using really human cells
and if
there are any um viruses in it
it would get classified either as bsl2
or bsl 2 plus i believe
there is a classification chart
available from the nih
that could guide us a little bit better
on that
but other than that you know there are
several features on the ma
that make it a fairly you know
airtight system if you will in terms of
aerosol containment itself
thank you dr sony we have another
question uh this is the last audience
question
so far how to um this is a question
about how to improve a better cell
sorting test before real cell separation
um i think i can answer that uh so um
uh if if you're asking about
uh tube or actually uh in fact for
both tube or plate sorting if you are
talking about targeting of
uh cells into into those collection
devices
you can do a quick test sort um it
really doesn't have to take
a lot of cells um because each droplet
with a cell in it is only around
you know three to ten nanoliters you can
do a quick
test sort onto a parafilm um
uh you know covering the tubes or plate
cover uh making sure that
the droplets uh will will hit the
centers of those well centers of those
tubes
um and like i said it doesn't take many
cells to do this test
to get a small puddle uh you need only
30 40
cells so you would do this test sort um
and
that that will make sure that the cells
can can go down the tube or into the
plate
thank you again dr sony and dr coolness
do you have any
final comments for our audience
um well if there are any more questions
please feel free to get in touch with us
at sonybiotechnology.com
great thank you so much and before we go
i would like to thank the audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
we would like to once again thank dr
sony and dr coolness for their time
today and for their important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor sony biotechnology
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
you can view the webinar on demand lab
roots will alert you via email when it's
available for replay
that's all for now until next time
goodbye